there's no better way than to check
something really simple and show you how
you would derive it using Huffman tree
techniques I am going to construct a
tree from the probabilities and I'm
gonna go up and I'll hope I don't run
out of space all these probabilities add
up to one
order them starting with the highest at
the left and they lowest at the right
you can do this way around if you like
long as you're consistent about it now
there's no problem here because they're
all a quarter they're ordered already
the Huffman algorithm then says group in
twos from the right successively by
going through this I hope it'll be clear
what I mean starting at the right take
the lowest two probabilities that you
can see so I group these together as the
branches of a tree computer scientists
always draw their trees nearly always
upside down the leaves if you like the
base of the trees down here but the
actual root where it Springs from is up
at the top if you group a quarter and a
quarter together that gives it combined
probability of a half that node these
two probabilities have been coped with
in some sense you're now left with 2/3
probability situation take the lowest
two probabilities you can see if there's
any ambiguity about which you should
choose then choose the rightmost set of
probabilities well here there's no
problem so the next stage for the two
lowest probabilities is to group those
together and make a 1/2 combined
probability they're done the next stage
so this is almost going like recursively
back up the tree is to say R but we now
group these together the half and the
half we've now reassured ourselves of
all the probabilities here when grouped
together and added up come to 1.0 and
would be in deep trouble if they didn't
that is you're Huffman tree with those
probabilities the next thing you do is
just great fun these to decorate the
tree
I now want to from this work out what
the correct code the minimal code should
be for a given state starting at the
root of the tree
I always annotate the left going branch
with zero and the right going bra with a
one you can do it the other way around
uniformly throughout if you want to it
will come to a so different looking
Huffman code but it will have just the
same properties as the one I'm going to
derive when you come to this node and
you say I'm now going to descend to the
left again the rule is you add a zero of
what you've already got
you own it with zero zero how about this
state you come down on a zero but then
you go to the right every time you go to
the right
you add a 1 to what you've already got
we've already got a 0 out of 1 and here
we are look it works for the rest go
down to the right with a 1 then go down
to the left every time you go down to
the left add a 0 to what you've got
there we are
1 down to the right had a 1 that's that
one so there we are
what Huffman basically said in 1952 when
he did this was that this was the method
of getting a compact code in other words
the best you could possibly do for those
probabilities and I think David
Huffman's thesis is famous for only
being about 12 pages long I think many
of us would love to write a thesis
saying here is an unsolved problem I
have done it please give me a PhD yes
it's only 12 pages long but to be fair
to to those who were examining him it's
easy enough to prove that it works for
something like this which is so easy
because they are all exact negative
powers of 2 the harder thing is to prove
that it still gives the best possible
compromise even when the probabilities
don't work in your favor I have to sort
of sound a word of warning here let me
do the San Francisco entropy on the San
Francisco page if I can find space to
squeeze it in
if you remember the entropy is the sum
over all the weather states they
typically see in textbooks things
looking like this from the first weather
to the fourth weather situation take the
sum over P I log to the base 2 1 over P
I that of course comes down to being the
sum over minus P I log P I is equally
valid so what we do for the entropy is
we take the weighted sum of the
probability of the state happening times
the log of the probability of it
happening and we've discovered in the
entropy in compression video the entropy
overall is 2 bits of course it is it's
exact hours of to all that whether
states are the same but then we worked
out to the average length of the code
and the average length of the code is 2
bits yeah they all occur with
probability or quarter but they're all
two bits long so the average length of
the message you set is also 2 bits this
is so simple and so straightforward
that's the efficiency which is measured
as H over L in this particular case is 2
to 2 bits Ferntree two bits there is
length which is equal to 100% you can
hit the entropy limit with this weather
system encoded in this way because these
probabilities are all negative powers of
two for those of you who've encountered
entropy in physics or chemistry take
great care information theorists call
entropy H don't do that in your
chemistry exam in chemistry h is
reserved for the amount of heat in a
system and certainly remembering back to
my chemistry days i think they use the
symbol s for entropy so don't get
confused shannon used h
french brief so I will what about if we
have
whether States or some system where
these probabilities are not exact powers
of two we'll look at a fishing trip
let's say that we want a system with
probabilities of one third one third one
nine one nine one ninth this person with
a pretty good set of fishing kiss and a
good selection of fish to catch actually
at the end of the day ends up that one
third of his or her catch is called
another one third is sea bass one ninth
proportion of the catch is tuna one
ninth is a baby shark and we got a bit
stuck for inspiration here Barracuda
well you could get them all from the
same boat I don't know but let's say
this person wants to transmit back in
the shortest possible toad what the
predominant catches that he's gone so he
wants to signal whether he's you know
he's got a good lot of con today or is
it bass or is it whatever first thing
always is check your probabilities add
up that except to 3/3 which is one here
we go Huffman tree we're still going to
use log to the base 2 from the right
take the pair of lowest probabilities
you can see and those are these 1/9 so
that makes two nines cross out the ones
you've coped with you've now got one
third one third one ninth to ninth the
two lowest probabilities you can still
see are to 9 and 1/9
which is going to combine to make a 1/3
next stage the two lowest probabilities
you can say well you've got a third a
third a third we have coped with that
we've coped with that if you get a
choice of either that pair or that pair
of thirds it doesn't matter which
actually you'll get slightly different
codes but with similar properties one
third and this 1/3 gets combined into
two thirds and the final stage you can
all see is dead easy
we triumphantly find that we do add up
to a total probability of 1.0 now comes
the fun bit of writing down the Huffman
codes for this in binary you're
descending left so that's a zero you're
going right so that's a 1 you've come
down on this one so that's a 1 and then
a 0 this arm gets 1 1 but then you come
down here that's going to be 1 1 0
therefore this arm coming down here is 1
1 1 this one is 1 1 0 and that one is 1
1 so those are your Huffman codes when
you take H as the sum of your this is
now from state number 1 1 2 3 4 5 state
number 1 is I've caught cards day number
2 is I've caught bass up to five of your
minus P I log to the base 2 of P I you
are going to find to your dismay that
the entropy comes out to being 2 point 1
1 or 3 bits look this up on my
calculator if any of you aren't sure how
to take log the base 2 of 1/3 then we
must keep ganging up on Brady to do a
number file on powers of number bases
and logarithms the average length when
you work it out is 2 point 2 to 2 bits
so the efficiency is equal to 1 over the
other two point 1 1 3 over 2 point 2 2 2
is equal to 95 point one percent
efficient not bad not bad but not nearly
as good as the weather stays why why is
because these things are not exact
negative powers of 2
with these things being exact negative
powers of three I can confidently
predict that if only we could calculate
entropy in trace so so long as your
properties of your line were such that
errors were relatively infrequent